it's Holi afternoon and Charles or Iago
has been searching for his
eleven-year-old son Caleb who was on the
ground floor of the two-story building
his neighbor's daughter 14 year old
Juliette kerreri is also missing she was
in a classroom above our yong-go has
come to get information from aid workers
helping parents trace missing children I
first came here in the morning but I did
not find them I have been to four
hospitals he also told me to go and
check in a motel after frantically
looking for them all day our youngest
son is found safe but Juliette
did not make it the collapse of the
primary school building happened when
morning classes were just starting
just as pupils were settling down to
begin lessons when I arrived the
children are under the rubble six of
them were dead we took them to the
mortuary government officials say
investigations into the cause of the
collapse have began the school for more
than eight hundred children was built of
iron sheets separated by a concrete slab
there appeared to have been poorly
reinforced all these are books that were
left behind
after the building collapsed children
who survived the tragedy have been
collecting some of the intact book
they'll be sorting them out later and
perhaps reused them you also have
community members who've been here all
day they are still trying to come to
terms with what happened
Kenyon's who can't afford to take their
children to expensive private schools or
get a place in crowded public
institutions bring them to chip a
community schools such as this learn
tragedies like this happen
the whole neighborhood comes to help I
don't have a student here or a pupil
here Medine have to come to the rescue
for any case of anything I'm a parent
after what had been a long and
traumatizing day some injured pupils
who've been taken to hospital were
discharged their parents eager to take
them home
but several other parents will be going
home alone Catherine saw a al Jazeera
marrow